[Musique]
le répertoire de notre invité compte un
nombre incalculable de titre il irrigue
la chanson française depuis plus de 60
ans avec un style très à part qui n'est
jamais vraiment rentré dans une case des
textes ciselés drôles ironique taquin
parfois grivois pas de choses
spectaculaires une voix une simple
guitare et un tabouret sur scène mais ne
vous fiez surtout pas à son air enjoué
ni à son petit sourire malicieux
n'écoutez pas ceux qui vous diront que
sont style est naïf et ses paroles
enfantines car il est bel et bien un
chanteur engagé cela fait plus de 60 ans
qu'il porte des albums au message fort
il traverse son époque avec un regard
incisif exigeant d'ailleurs pas un seul
de ces albums ne sort sans qu'un titre
ne fasse grincer des dents le zizi il
est joli colonies de vacances Lily et
aujourd'hui Paris saccagé provoquer des
polémiques ne le gênent pas du tout les
critiques ils les entend bien sûr mais
aucune ne le pas vraiment sur le fond
peut-être même qu'il les cherche qu'il
les provoque un peu après tout aurait-il
duré comme cela s'il n'avait pas dérangé
un artiste a-t-il un intérêt s'il ne
fait aucune vague posant lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard et bienvenue à vous Pierre Perret
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
au Dôme Tournon du Sénat auteur
compositeur interprète à l'origine d'une
trentaine d'albums dont le dernier ma
vieille carcasse vous dites les choses
avec le moins de filtre possible tel que
vous les ressentez c'est en tout cas ce
que l'on pense quand on vous entend au
risque parfois de choquer et peu importe
les réactions
je n'ai jamais fait volontairement mais
je dirais il y a pas d'apriori mais en
dehors de ça je ne sais pas si je mérite
vraiment tous les superlatifs que vous
avez grenier à l'instant si vous voulez
méritez vous avez une carrière
incroyable plus de 60 ans à plaire à un
public qui vous suit qui vous qui vous
est très fidèle vous dites que ça n'est
jamais commentaires de provoquer ces
mêmes pas devenu un peu une marque de
fabrique un moteur pour vous pas du tout
mais comme je suis très observateur de
la société
c'est travers m'arrive très vite je vois
très vite il y a je vois beaucoup de
choses très vite et
c'est vrai que j'ai une tendance
naturelle à mettre le doigt là où ça
fait mal et bon c'est malgré moi mais je
peux pas m'empêcher je disais que
c'était rare que l'un de vos albums ne
fasse pas de vagues parfois on a même
l'impression que vous leur tendez des
perches énormes je pense à Libération ou
à Laurent Ruquier qui vous ont un petit
peu taclés sur cette chanson Paris
saccagé finalement il tombe dans un
piège que vous leur que vous leur tendez
vous les avez vu ces réactions vous les
avez entendues
si ça lui fait du bien
Ruquier tant mieux pour lui bon moi
personnellement je
mal fait d'une chanson pas très bien
écrite même très vulgaire je savais pas
qu'il savait déjà écrire des chansons
donc je j'irai prendre des cours avec
lui dorénavant ça serait une bonne chose
pour moi et la vulgarité a été toujours
été un signe chez moi c'est connu je
suis avant tout un personnage vulgaire
qui a traversé le temps on se demande
bien pourquoi je vais citer quand même
quelques passages de Paris saccagé pour
que le public il nous écoute comprenne
bien de quoi on parle vous dites pauvre
Paris on les dit dans quel état ils
t'ont mis pauvres Paris devenu si cracra
on sait bien qu'il t'a fait ça c'est les
crânes de Piaf dégourdis qui bouffent
des graines à la mairie est-ce que la
mairie de Paris a réagi
j'ai reçu un très bel ouvrage sur Paris
magnifique de la part
du secrétaire de
premiers secrétaire de la mairie
et qui m'a dit regardez comment Paris
est beau ça a été la réaction
très gentiment lui envoyant d'ailleurs
mon album je lui ai dit on doit pas
avoir les mêmes lunettes
mais plus globalement plus généralement
est-ce que vous en voulez aux
responsables politiques est-ce que vous
les trouvez un peu déconnecté de leur
réalité de la réalité mais là en
l'occurrence ce qui s'est passé pour bon
je veux pas dégraisser spécialement
là-dessus mais pour avoir laissé ce
dégrader Paris comme ça c'est dégradé à
ce point là je dirais il faut vraiment y
mettre de la bonne volonté et
c'est très dommage parce que c'est vrai
que c'est la plus belle ville du monde
et ça sert un peu le cœur de voir
comment
on allait arriver à ce point-là de ces
dégradations je pense qu'il y a trop de
monde dans un endroit comme la mairie
par exemple de Paris pour gouverner un
bateau comme ça on des tributaires les
uns des autres d'un côté il y a les
écolos de l'autre il y a les politiques
de l'autre il y a la gauche il y a c'est
c'est tout de même il y a c'est
socialiste bon et moi j'ai toujours eu
le cœur à gauche
mais c'est pas pour autant que il faut
pas être lucide
là-dessus
c'est marrant parce que après la sortie
de la chanson j'ai eu des écoles disant
que c'était une chanson qui avait été
téléguidée par l'extrême droite alors je
savais pas que d'un coup j'étais tombé
dans l'extrême droite
c'est bon
vous savez il faut
les chansons il y en a il y en a très
peu qui vont pas poser de problème
des polémiques
toute ma vie j'ai connu que ça parce que
d'abord au début elles ont essayé d'être
interdites dans les radios aujourd'hui
il y a plus rien qui passe dans les
radios donc c'est pas grave mais
à chaque fois on m'a volé dans les
plumes en disant et ça
une des principales raisons avancées
d'abord c'est vulgaire dès qu'on dit la
vérité c'est vulgaire c'est voilà c'est
très intéressant que vous me disiez ça
maintenant parce que effectivement vous
faites ma transition j'ai une archive à
vous proposer qui nous a été envoyé
transmise par les Archives nationales
nos partenaires sur cette émission et je
vais décrire ce document pour les gens
qui nous écoutent et pour vous c'est une
liste de titres censurés en 1958 et deux
de vos chansons y figurent onésie mais
la chanson du Malin alors je suis allée
un peu voir les paroles notamment de la
chanson du malin pour comprendre
pourquoi cette chanson avait été
interdite je vais citer le refrain dans
le grand poulailler moi je plume je fais
griller tous ceux qu'on engraisse des
Vaux pas plats critiqueur lèche fesses
juge fripouillard tous les pandas tous
les jobards vous souveniez que cette
chanson avait été interdite
déjà je
il y a très longtemps que je suis sur le
même ligne j'ai j'avais été un
opportuniste de
je vais jamais suivi aucune mode j'ai
jamais suivi aucune directive de
personnes donc
c'est peut-être ça qui énerve Pierre
Perret c'est peut-être parce que
certainement extrêmement dépendant se
dérange toujours il faut être si on
n'est pas si on appartient pas à une
école
on devient suspect déjà tout de suite
c'est drôle parce que j'ai écrit cette
chanson
peu de temps après avoir écrit une des
toutes premières qui est sur le le
premier petit disque que j'ai enregistré
chez Barclay moi j'attends Adèle il y
avait une chanson qui s'appelle le
principal
et dans le principal en fait c'est la
première chanson que j'ai écrite un jour
sur un banc dans le boulevard
du Montparnasse en face le chien qui
fume
je disais dedans et en fait on retrouve
pratiquement
le même Picotin
rien à se mettre sous la dent depuis
fort longtemps le père la mère et le
fils fumé du maïs la famille fléau des
astrueux était sur eux et jusqu'à leur
chien bon Dieu qui fumait sa queue
cette Émilie sens sûrement à cause du
chien qui fume
et le refrain est le
principal il va nous donner du pain le
prince passe et leur donne du gourdin
[Musique]
si vous voulez c'est une parabole qu'on
a retrouvé
pratiquement régulièrement
tout au long de mon parcours très grande
continuité voilà et vous avez même été
donc censuré sur un titre qui ne
semblait pourtant pas incroyablement
provocant je pense aux jolies colonies
de vacances titre qui a fortement déplu
à Yvonne de Gaulle vous en souvenez vous
nous racontez à cause de pipi dans le
lavabo
qui avait chaud
pipi dans le lavabo ma vulgarité a
commencé là mais vous vous souvenez de
ce qu'elle a fait oui elle a téléphoné à
mon copain Dordain qui était à l'époque
le patron de Radio France et elle lui a
dit monsieur
nous vous serions reconnaissants elle a
mis le pluriel
nous vous serions reconnaissants de ne
plus programmer cette chanson que nous
considérons comme étant la honte de la
France
dans déjà dès 1966 je suis devenu la
honte de la France ça nous a fait rire
même à Dordain qui m'a dit t'en fais pas
et le lendemain je suis repassé sur ces
antennes
hier j'ai glissé dessus une chaise en
faisant pipi dans le lavabo et pour ce
titre certaines émissions de télévision
vous ont demandé de tousser au moment de
prononcer faire pipi dans le lavabo
exactement c'est chez guildux d'ailleurs
puisque elle était numéro 1 à tous les
parades cette chanson et le lendemain de
il avait sa chanson des parade mais à la
télé et il m'a dit tu sais
j'ai des problèmes
il faudrait que tu arrange le coup avec
quand tu arrives à pipi dans le lavabo
il faut que tu tousses
tu m'écoutes je suis pas enrhumé
je
ne vais pas tousser
vous avez refusé
le patron de la télé qui s'appelait
contamine
a menacé de t'interdire
de télé à partir de ce moment-là tu
seras interdit six mois de télé
c'est pas grave mais moi tu veux que je
la charte ou pas oui oui chante mais je
t'en prie essaie de faire quelque chose
pour
occulter ça et pas du tout
j'allais mon copain Georges barrier qui
était réalisateur à l'époque qui était
qui était au manège et j'ai dit George
quand je vais dire pipi dans le lavabo
tu me fais un plan comme ça
convocateur
parce que ça m'énerve
et genre je la fais et j'ai dit hier
j'ai glissé sur une chaise en faisant
pipi dans le lavabo
alors à partir de là on m'a dit bon vous
êtes interdit pendant 6 mois de télé et
c'est ce qui s'est passé et non non
est mort interdit vraiment pendant six
mois mais moi je les ai interdits après
pour un an parce que au bout de 6 mois
ils m'ont demandé de refaire de la télé
j'ai dit non je viendrai pas chez vous
pendant un an vraiment j'ai privilégié
la liberté de ton de parole de tout
d'abord
j'ai retrouvé une archive dans laquelle
vous disiez que les lettres d'insultes
que vous receviez parce que vous en
receviez beaucoup étaient toujours
anonyme et vous avez répondu dans cet
archive moi je signe mes chansons et
aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde où les
réseaux sociaux sont le royaume de
l'anonymat de l'insulte anonyme et j'ai
envie de connaître votre avis parce que
j'ai été regarder vos réseaux sociaux et
qu'est-ce que vous les alimentez vos
réseaux sociaux vous êtes extrêmement
connectés que vous inspire cet univers
du des réseaux sociaux ou vous partagez
vous jouez le jeu
je pense qu'il faut partager parce que
si on déplaît à quelqu'un et qu'il le
dit ben parfois ça fait réfléchir on
peut dire est-ce qu'il a pas raison
après tout non je trouve que tout bon à
part les insultes gratuites dont on sent
que
c'est atteigneux qui vous veut du mal
pourquoi on sait pas il y a ça aussi
mais disons que dans l'ensemble j'ai
vraiment
98% de commentaires flamboyants
magnifiques et et quelque part
quand j'ai fait un concert le lendemain
je vois des sur les réseaux à la soirée
que j'ai passé tout ça ça me réjouit
parce que
on a besoin de ça les artistes ont
besoin de
d'être assurés quelque part et même si
mais moi je serai jamais un type blasé
voilà parce que sinon je serais plus là
je continuerai pas
pur plaisir
que je continue à chanter jusqu'à ce que
on veuille plus de moi ou que je tienne
plus sur mes cannes et que j'ai pu déjà
la voix n'est plus la même certes mais
j'arrive sur le ton
tout va bien mais
sinon moi c'est il y a que la passion
qui me guide et le public vous le rend
bien j'ai retrouvé un article élogieux
écrit par l'un de vos fans Michel
Quimper sur le site vos enchanteurs le
quotidien de la chanson et il écrit ceci
tant que Pierre Perret sera là nous
aurons notre antidote notre vaccin à la
connerie et la certitude que la vie vaut
le coup de se battre et de s'aimer d'en
rire et dans chialer quelle belle
hommage ah ça c'est beau mais je je
connaissais pas j'avais pas entendu ça
il est pas loin du compte
la vie vaut le coup de se battre comme
il le dit même si ça se termine
forcément mal mais bien sûr bien sûr
vous savez j'ai toujours laissé une
porte de sortie au bout de mes chansons
il y a jamais une chanson pessimiste on
a envie de se [__] sur la tête
chaussures et d'aller se pendre
mon petit loup années un exemple parmi
les chansons si vous voulez ça pourrait
servir de symboles mon petit loup c'est
horrible ce qu'on a fait à mon petit
loup c'est ce que je laisse supposer
tout au long de la chanson mais
oublie les petits cons qui t'ont fait ça
voilà
il continue la vie vaut d'être vécue
t'arrête pas ça avant d'être le pire
Péret que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
vous avez été le petit garçon de
Castelsarrasin dans le Tarn-et-Garonne
fils de Maurice et de Claudia qui tenait
le café du pont au bord du Canal du Midi
entouré de gens humbles dites-vous et je
vous cite j'ai évolué au milieu des
ouvriers je sais ce que c'est la sueur
je sais ce que c'est les gens qui
meurent de fatigue à 50 ans et qui
viennent se consoler en se noyant un peu
dans la gnôle ou le vin est-ce que
l'artiste que vous êtes aujourd'hui doit
beaucoup à ces gens que vous avez pris
le temps d'observer à ces gens humbles
tout est parti de là
tout tout ce que je vois où j'entends
aujourd'hui
j'apprends rien
je veux dire on peut me dire ce qu'on
voudra sur la sur la vie sur l'humanité
sur la dégueulasserie de la vie et sur
la beauté de ce qu'on peut rencontrer en
simplement rencontrant un enfant ou un
personnage
improbable que
qui peut vous enrichir
et il faut savoir picorer partout faut
savoir écouter tout le monde c'est très
important de savoir écouter les enfants
par exemple
mais
les vieillards c'est pas mal aussi ceux
qui ont pris du recul qui parlent peu et
quand ils ouvrent la bouche
qui vous enrichissent
et
il faut se nourrir de tout partout tout
le monde de tout le monde dans tous les
univers mais pour moi vraiment tout a
démarré là tout a démarré au café du
pont parce que
oui je l'ai vu la misère
et physique et morale de celui que vous
êtes aujourd'hui Pierre Perret quel
conseil donneriez-vous au petit garçon
que vous étiez que lui diriez-vous avant
qu'il ne se lance dans la vie
tu aurais dû commencer à lire encore
plus tôt
je lui dirai ça pourquoi ben parce que
une des choses qui me sert le cœur le
plus aujourd'hui c'est de voir les
enfants qui lisent pas
avec leur tablette là comme ça toute la
journée je trouve ça terrifiant
terrifiant parce que vous votre amour de
la langue française il vient de là il
vient de la lecture et de la découverte
de quelques auteurs c'est ça voilà moi
j'ai commencé à
entre 10 et 12 ans à lire un petit peu
à 14 ans je me suis aperçu du vide
sidéral qui était le mien quand je me
suis inscrit au conservatoire en cours
de déclamation et quand j'ai été
confronté au texte de racine de Molière
de musée etc
j'étais
au bord du fils
c'est une image imbécile mais
à ce moment-là vraiment je me suis
immergé dans la lecture de la
littérature j'ai commencé à découvrir
les poètes après les surréalistes après
l'humour et en parallèle même j'ai quand
j'ai commencé à lire les humoristes
c'est une planète qui m'échappait
complètement et j'ai dit mais c'est pas
possible
le seul décodeur que je connaissais
c'était mon père
et c'était pas le même humour parce que
quand je disais Mark Twain où elle fonce
allait
ça me faisait réfléchir mais en même
temps éclater de rire avec un rire un
éclin de rire que n'avait pas les autres
à l'école je connaissais pas beaucoup de
gamins qui avaient le sens de l'humour
et aujourd'hui une trentaine d'écoles
portent votre nom et on propose même vos
chansons en sujet de bac quelle belle
réponse à Yvonne de Gaulle non oui
quelle belle réponse à tous les autres à
tous ceux qui vous ont critiqué ou qui
continuent de vous critiquer
voilà c'est un remboursement c'est la
chose à laquelle à laquelle je suis le
plus sensible avec tous les honneurs que
je peux avoir que j'ai eu tous les bravo
tout bon c'est merveilleux mais ça c'est
une vraie reconnaissance et si quelque
chose me touchait bien ça
j'ai des photos à vous proposer Pierre
Perret ça fait partie des rituels pour
que vous connaissez alors on a pensé à
celle-ci pour vous c'est une photo de la
mobilisation contre l'autoroute a69
entre Toulouse et Castres c'est dans le
coin où vous avez grandi les travaux ont
commencé mais les militants écologistes
s'insurgent contre la destruction
d'arbres centenaire langloutissement de
terres agricoles entre autres et j'ai
pensé à cette photo pour vous parce que
je sais que vous êtes sensible aux
questions environnementales et que vous
avez chanté l'environnement il y a déjà
bien longtemps et bien avant tout le
monde et tout le monde m'a pris pour
Charlotte parce que quand j'ai écrit à
l'époque il y a au moins 30 ans en 75
vous écrivez donnez-nous des jardins
donnez-nous des jardins oui en 98 vous
écrivez vers de colère de colère alors
faire de colère dans les radios m'a dit
mais pourquoi tu écris ça j'ai dit mais
parce que c'est tout ce qui arrive en
courant à 200 à l'heure
on va être dans une merde dans dans 30
ans
mais arrête ça n'intéresse personne tous
les programmateurs des radios me disent
ça n'intéresse personne et ben voilà je
lis les paroles quand même parce que
c'est vrai que c'est assez visionnaire
vu ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui je suis vert
vert je suis vert de colère contre ces
pauvres types qui bousillent la terre
cette jolie terre que nos pères nos
grands-pères avaient su préserver durant
des millénaires
j'ai une autre photo à vous proposer il
s'agit de Marlène Schiappa secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire ancienne secrétaire d'État
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes elle a marqué les esprits par
sa façon bien à elle de défendre la
cause des femmes les droits des femmes
qui ont été la grande cause nationale du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et
là j'ai pensé à vous parce que c'est
aussi un sujet qui vous touche les
violences conjugales vous en avez parlé
là aussi et vous avez dit un jour les
femmes battues je les ai vues je les ai
entendus j'ai vu leur bleu oui bah oui
j'ai écrit une chanson là-dessus puis
j'ai écrit des tas d'autres chansons en
évoquant ces problèmes là
domestique
qui se passe tous les jours à la maison
il y a une des premières chansons qui
étaient partis très forte sur les radios
qui s'appelle à cause du gosse et qui a
été interdite au bout du troisième jour
parce qu'ils ont reçu 3000 lettres par
jour de de
protestation de la part des couples qui
se tapaient qui se tapent sur la gueule
tous les jours voilà et ça ils aiment
pas qu'on leur dise les gens qui se
tapent sur la gueule arrêtez ils aiment
pas comment vous en êtes devenus à
écrire sur ce sujet
parce que j'ai
vous avez évoqué l'endroit où j'habitais
à la cité de l'usine dans le café du
pont je peux vous dire qu'à l'époque
dans le coin ce genre de phénomène
c'était assez quotidien
et les femmes qui venaient avec des
cocards comme ça à chercher leur mari au
bistrot qui pouvaient pas se décrocher
du bar et
même dans le café il pouvait elle
pouvait s'en prendre une
donc
je vous dis j'ai été habitué très tôt à
ce genre de situation ce genre de
spectacle qu'un gosse
moi ça me marquait un point que c'était
j'avais 10 ans 11 ans 8 ans
mais c'était déjà
c'était pas Zola mais c'est on sortait
de ça c'était pas loin c'était vraiment
la façon de vivre au quotidien de ces
gens là ils étaient déjà épuisés à
40 ans 45 ans ils en pouvaient plus
et ce type là de phénomène dont je veux
me parler je peux vous dire que
je connaissais voilà je connaissais très
tôt et j'en étais déchiré déchiré vous
l'avez observé vous y avez été sensible
Pierre Perret j'ai une dernière question
qui est en lien avec le lieu dans lequel
nous sommes aujourd'hui vous l'avez
remarqué nous sommes entouré de quatre
statues qui représentent chacune une
vertu il y a ici la sagesse ici la
prudence ici la justice et derrière moi
l'éloquence avez-vous déjà réfléchi
peut-être puisque vous connaissez
l'émission à une vertu qui vous parle
plus que les autres ou qui vous
caractérise vous peut-être
personnellement
parce que la justice j'y crois pas
beaucoup c'est vrai la prudence j'ai
jamais trop pété
je pense que au contraire il faut être
audacieux il faut il faut foncer surtout
là où on vous attend pas souvent parce
que
quand on n'aime pas la Convention on
n'est pas prudent voilà
l'éloquence l'éloquence se trouve cette
ce manque toujours
l'éloquence le vocabulaire le français
voilà c'est le message que l'on
retiendra entre autres merci infiniment
Pierre Perret d'avoir été notre invité
dans un monde à regarder merci de nous
avoir fait cette joie cette honneur et
au public de public c'est la merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine émission à retrouver en replay
et en podcast à très vite merci
[Musique]